[Music]
the year after I reached yet oh the
sixth year of an SCI that was
established the so called Treaty of the
five nations and the port of Yokohama
was formally opened for trade with
foreign countries one day I went to
Yokohama for sightseeing there was
nothing of the town of Yokohama then a
few temporary dwellings had been erected
here and there as posts for the foreign
trade and in these the pioneer merchants
were living and showing their wares to
my disappointment when I tried to speak
with them no one seemed to understand me
at all nor was I able to understand
anything spoken by any one of the
foreigners I met neither could I read
anything of the signboards over the
shops nor the labels on the bottles
which they had for sale there was not a
single recognizable word in any of the
inscriptions or in any speech it might
have been English or French for what I
knew on the very next day after
returning from Yokohama I took up a new
aim in my life and determined to begin
the study of English but needless to say
there was no teacher of English than in
yet oh I did not know how to begin I
found after inquiring around there was
an interpreter named Moriyama takashi ro
who had been called from nagasaki to
help in the negotiation proceedings of
the new treaty I heard that this man
knew some English though his speciality
was Dutch I went at once to Marianas
house and implored him to teach me
English at that time a young lad had
reached yet Oh from Nagasaki we heard
that he knew some English and we tried
to get some pronunciation from him then
occasionally there were shipwrecked
Japanese fishermen who were brought back
by foreign ships these poor men had
formerly by government degree not being
permitted to re-enter this land but
after the new policy of open ports came
into effect they were allowed to return
home whenever we heard of any such men
we called on them at their lodgings and
asked them to give us any English they
knew
in truth Dutch and English were both
strange languages written sideways of
the same origin our knowledge of Dutch
could be applied directly to English our
one time fear was a groundless illusion
the year after I was settled in yellow
the sixth year of anti the government of
the Shogun made a great decision to send
a ship of war to the United States an
enterprise never before attempted since
the foundation of the Empire on this
ship I was to have the good fortune of
visiting America
[Music]
this video is sponsored by Magellan the
premier documentary streaming service so
here we are 100 days until lockdown and
I can now confirm that Coco has watched
all of Magellan's documentaries and now
runs the channel
how are you Coco okay luckily for Coco
Magellan have a huge range of
fascinating documentaries everything
from ancient history to space including
some beautiful nature documentaries my
personal recommendation this week would
be the Jupiter enigma an eye-opening
documentary on Jupiter's huge effect on
the early Earth and a great companion to
our new channel the entire history of
the earth
a longtime supporter of content from the
history brothers Magellan TV is
basically a Netflix for documentaries
with the widest range of history content
available anywhere click on the link in
the description for an exclusive
month-long free trial for voices of the
past viewers thanks
though it had been called a warship the
vessel was a very small sailing craft
equipped with an auxilary steam engine
of 100 horsepower which was used for
maneuvering in and out of harbors in the
open sea she must depend entirely on
sale the government had purchased her
from the Dutch for 25 thousand Ryo a few
years before and had named her the
Cameron Maru this voyage of Cameron Maru
was an epoch-making adventure of our
nation every member of the crew was
determined to take the ship across
unassisted by a foreigner it seems to me
now that the reason for granting my wish
to go on the boat so easily must have
been that such an unusual Enterprise as
the voyage was to be there were not many
volunteers no sooner did we get out into
the open sea that we ran into storms and
continued to have rough weather all the
way across in the rocking shepper quiet
dignified meal was impossible so I used
to pile my rice in my purloined Bowl and
pour soup and everything over it take it
to the side of the cabin and eat
standing up for a whole month we saw
nothing but the waves and the clouds
once we sighted a sailboat said to be an
American vessel carrying Chinese workmen
over to America that was the only thing
we saw during the voyage
the four or five American sailors on our
ship were found to be using more water
than they were supposed to one of the
officers told captain Brooke about it
and the latter replied instantly you may
shoot any semen found wasting water any
such person is guilty of general treason
to the ship
no admonition or inquiry is necessary
you may feel free to shoot him at once
our water supply was thus made to hold
out and we with the entire crew of 96
men reached land at San Francisco after
37 days I am willing to admit my pride
in this accomplishment for Japan the
facts of these it was not until the
sixth year of Kay that a steamship was
seen for the first time it was only in
the second year of an say that we began
to study navigation from the Dutch in
Nagasaki by 1860 the science was
sufficiently understood to enable us to
sail the ship across the Pacific this
means that about seven years after the
first sight of a steamship after only
about five years of practice the
Japanese people made a trans-pacific
crossing without help from foreign
experts I think we can without undue
pride boast before the world of this
courage and skill our welcome on shore
was certainly worthy of a friendly
people
they did everything for us and they
could not have done more the feeling on
their part must have been like that of a
teacher receiving his old pupil several
years after graduation for it was their
Commodore Perry who had effected the
opening of our country eight years
before and now here we were on our first
visit to America as soon as we came on
shore we found we were to be driven off
in carriages to a hotel while we were
resting in the hotel city officials and
various dignitaries came to offer
entertainment we were given quarters in
the official residence of the Navy
station on Mare Island our hosts knew
that we Japanese were accustomed to
different diets so they arranged that
our food instead of being served should
be prepared by our own cook in the
quarters allotted to us but the
officials being very kind and desiring
to satisfy the Japanese love for seafood
sent fish every day also on learning the
Japanese custom of bathing frequently
they had baths prepared daily this
generous treatment in every way brought
to mind an old expression of ours as if
our host had put us on the palm of his
hand to see that we lacked nothing
on our part there were many confusing
and embarrassing moments
for we were quite ignorant of the
customs and habits of American life for
instance we were very surprised even by
the carriages as part of our very first
experiences on seeing the vehicle with
horses are attached to it
we should easily have guessed what it
was but really we did not identify our
mode of conveyance until the door had
been opened we were seated inside and
the horses had started off then we
realized we were riding in a carriage
behind horses all of us wore the usual
pair of swords at our sides and the hemp
sandals so attired we were taken to the
modern hotel there we noticed covering
the interior the valuable carpets and
rugs which in Japan only the more
wealthy could buy from the importers
shop at so much a square inch to make
purses and tobacco pouches with here the
carpet was laid over an entire room
something quite astounding and upon this
costly fabric walked our hosts wearing
the shoes with which they had come in
from the streets we followed them in our
hemp sandals immediately bottles were
brought in suddenly an explosion the
popping of champagne when the glasses
were passed around we noticed strange
fragments floating in them hardly did we
expect to find ice in the warm spring
weather some of the party swallowed
these floating particles others expelled
them suddenly others bravely chewed them
this was an adventure finding out that
they were ice
I wanted to have a smoke but seeing no
tobacco tray such as in Japan is placed
before the smoker to hold the burning
charcoal brazier and the bamboo ash
receiver
I took a light from the open fireplace
perhaps there was an ash trainer and a
box of matches on the table but I did
not recognize them as such
I finished my smoke but finding no ash
receiver I took out some of the tissue
paper which we carried in place of
handkerchiefs and wrapping the ashes in
it crushed them very carefully and place
the ball in my sleeve after a while I
took out the paper to have another smoke
some wisps of smoke were trickling from
my sleeve the light that I had thought I
had crushed out was quietly setting me
afire after all these embarrassing
incidents I thought I could well
sympathize with the Japanese bride her
new family whom the bride has never met
before welcome her tell her to make
herself at home and do everything to
make her comfortable one laughs with her
another engages her in conversation all
happy with the new addition to the
family in the midst of all this the
bride has to sit trying to look pleasant
but in our efforts she goes on making
mistakes and blushes every time before
leaving Japan I the independent soul a
carefree student who could look the
world in the face had feared nothing but
on arriving in America I was turned
suddenly into a shy self-conscious
blushing bride the contrast was indeed
funny even to myself
[Music]
one evening our host had said that some
ladies and gentlemen were having a dance
party and they would be glad for us to
attend it we went to our dismay we could
not quite make out what they were doing
the ladies and gentlemen seem to be
hopping about the room together as funny
as it was we knew it would be rude to
laugh and we controlled our expressions
with difficulty as the dancing went on
these were but a few of the instances of
our the wildermann to the strange
customs of American society on taking
leave our host and hostess kindly
offered us horses to ride home on this
pleased us for a chance to ride
horseback again was a relief especially
did captain Kimura enjoy this for he was
an accomplished horseman who used to
ride every day in yeto we touched whip
to the horses and rode back to our
quarters at a trot the Americans watched
us and exclaimed at the Japanese ability
in riding so neither of us knew much
about the other at all our hosts in San
Francisco were very considerate in
showing us examples of modern industry
I'm sure that our attentive hosts
thought they were showing us something
entirely new naturally looking for a
surprise at each new device of modern
engineering but on the contrary there
was really nothing new at least to me I
knew the principle of the Telegraph even
if I had not actually seen the machine
before rather I was surprised by
entirely different things in American
life first of all there seemed to be an
enormous waste of iron everywhere in
garbage piles on the sea Shores
everywhere I found lying old tins empty
cans and broken tools this was
remarkable to us for in yet Oh after a
fire there would be hundreds of poor
people swarming in the ruined district
looking for nails in the charred wood so
valuable was metal in Japan
then too I was surprised at the high
cost of daily commodities in California
we had to pay a half dollar for a bottle
of oysters and they're only 20 or 30 in
the bottle of that in Japan the price of
so many would only be sent or two things
social political and economic proved
most inexplicable one day on a sudden
thought I asked a gentleman where the
descendants of George Washington might
be he replied I think there is a woman
who is directly descended from
Washington I don't know where she is now
but I think I have heard she is married
his answer was so very casual that
shocked me of course I knew that America
was a republic with a new president
every four years but I could not help
feeling that the family of Washington
should be regarded as apart from other
families my reasoning was based on the
reverence in Japan for the founders of
the great lines of rulers like that for
Yasu of the Tokugawa family of Shogun's
really deified in the popular mind so I
remember the intense astonishment I felt
at receiving this indifferent answer
about the Washington family as for
scientific inventions and industrial
machinery there was no great novelty in
them for me it was more in matters of
life and conventions of social customs
and ways of thinking that I found myself
at a loss in America
I've already described the generosity of
our hosts and the people in San
Francisco not only did they repair the
damaged parts of our vessel but they
were thoughtful enough to build lockers
in convenient places on board for the
use of the crew when the ship was ready
and we were preparing to set sail on the
homeward voyage we inquired how much we
should have to pay for the repair of our
ship and the expenses we were met with a
kindly smile and we were obliged to save
away with our obligations unpaid before
sailing the interpreter Nakayama and
myself each bought a copy of Webster's
dictionary this I know was the very
first importation of Webster's into
Japan in spite of the general public
dislike of all foreign studies students
in my school gradually increased after
my return from America during my stay in
San Francisco I had come in contact with
foreigners had heard their language and
made a special effort to improve my
knowledge of English but as yet my
knowledge of English was not sufficient
I still had to have much recourse to my
dutch english dictionary though i called
myself a teacher i was still a student
along with those i was instructing
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]